Game of Thrones is back after the
longest off-season ever and episode 1 of
season 7 sets the stage for the
conflicts ahead IO is at the twins
wearing the face of Walder Frey who she
killed last season it's not clear
exactly how the magic of the faceless
man works but by wearing welders face
aya takes his appearance and voice and
everything and uses this disguise to
gather the phrase at a feast she talks
of the red wedding when the phrase kill
die is mother and brother and others and
then with poisoned wine aya kills the
phrase sparing only the women this
revenge was a long time coming and is
clearly pleased with her work but is
this really justice the main people
behind the red wedding Walder and Tywin
and ruse and Lothar and black Walder
they're already dead were all these Frey
is really guilty and deserving of death
there's a similar thing in the books
where Catelyn is resurrected as a Lady
Stoneheart who mercilessly kills all the
phrase you can find but it's not really
clear if the people she kills are all
guilty she even tries to hang Brienne
and pod so Stoneheart makes us question
whether violent vengeance is rife and
similarly is killing is questioned when
she runs into ed sheeran and his
Lannister mates this is a humanizing
scene where a bunch of nameless red
shirt soldiers show that they too have
personalities and families and dreams
they are Lannister soldiers have
probably done bad things but higher
realizes that they still deserve to live
maybe the same was true of some of these
phrase ayahs arc has made her a ruthless
killer but she still is capable of mercy
and humanity and that's one of the
themes of this episode justice and
vengeance vs. mercy and compassion after
the intro a dark fog rolls in with the
night king and white walkers leading the
army of the dead which includes a few
undead giants this giant is missing an
eye so some fans think it's the corpse
of one one who died at Winterfell but
when one lost his right eye this guy his
left eye so it must be some other
one-eyed giant 12 foot tall zombie
giants
are pretty scary and in the books there
are also undead bears and birds and
things in the water and I spiders even
rumors of ice dragons maybe we'll see
some of these this season also it's cool
to see the darkness brought by the White
Walkers because the walkers aren't just
frosty blokes who like the cold and dark
they bring the cold and dark they kind
of are the cold and dark
they are winter so the walkers might be
connected to this world's irregular
seasons maybe the seasons will become
normal
after the walkers are defeated if the
walkers are defeated one of their great
opponents is bran now called the
three-eyed Raven because he's got
psychic powers and [ __ ] he arrives at
the wall with Meera Reed and Ed of the
Nights Watch lets them through some
people thought that this mark the the
night King made on bran last season
might let the White Walkers pass through
or break the wall when bran enters but
it looks like the walls still standing
for now at Winterfell
King John snow holds a meeting with the
north he says they got to get
dragonglass to fight the White Walkers
because dragonglass can kill White
Walkers and he sends torment and the
wildlings to defend East watch one of
the castles on the wall for centuries
wildlings have attacked the wall but now
with a common enemy the wildlings and
the north stand together John says that
all northerners including the children
will join in the war against the walkers
Robert Glover and Lyanna Mormont argue
over whether girls should be allowed to
fight and it's decided that children of
both sexes will join in the war it's
pretty crazy how in a world like
Westeros gender equality can mean
conscripting ten-year-old girls to fight
and die hidden zombie hordes John and
Sansa argue over whether the umber and
Karstark families whose leaders betrayed
the Starks for Bolton should be allowed
to keep their castles or be replaced
Littlefinger enjoys seeing Sansa and
John divided but John decides to keep
the old families and accepts Earth's
from their new young rulers a Lascar
Stark is in the books she has a plot
about John helping her deal with her
uncle while Ned amber is invented for
the show it's cool how he's got this
cross on his clothes representing the
ombré chains the old Amber's had
something similar Sansa
John talked afterwards and basically
John is a decent ruler but he could
benefit from SAMHSA's advice over the
last six seasons Sansa's learned
politics from the best more you could
say from the worst John's mostly learned
from his uncle Ned who is a great bloke
but lost his head because he was too
dumb or too merciful maybe to survive
the stalks get a letter from Cersei who
demands they come south and kneel
there's a long history of stocks coming
south and dying there Ricard Brandon
Liana
Ned Robb so it's smart of John and Sansa
to stay put
Cersei is a problem but it's the walkers
who threaten all add the capital Jaime
and Cersei Lannister chat on a map so as
he talks about how he hates Tyrion who
she believes killed Joffrey which he
didn't and that he killed Tywin which he
actually did in the books there's a
prophecy that Circe's brother will kill
her says he thinks this means Tyrion but
some readers think Jaime go watch that
video says he also reveals her feelings
about her son Tommen who committed
suicide last season it was kind of weird
how calm and cold says he was about
Tommen's death now we learn that she
feels the Tommen betrayed her
by going over to the faith you'd think
that she'd feel grief that her son died
alone and confused and afraid but Cersei
hardened her heart against her son
Tommen if this is how she treats her kid
just imagine how she'll drink her
enemies as Jaime points out things look
bad for the Lannisters
so he's surrounded Daenerys is invading
from the east with her allies in Dorne
and the reach King John is in the north
and with the death of Walder Frey the
Lannisters have no allies left so so she
decides to make a new friend
King euron greyjoy
Euron sails into King's Landing with his
red eye on the iron Bond ships in the
books
Euron ship is called the silence it
screwed by mutes and mongrels painted
red to hide the blood and when men see
his sails they pray in season six of the
show some people felt Iran was kind of
boring
just another gruff bearded white bloke
who shouts a lot but now Iran's
different more expressive and colorful
and naughty like a peanut M&M a bit more
like the Euron of the books though not
as sorceress and scary Jamie feels
insecure that this black cloud Jack
Sparrow is hitting on his sister so he
reminds her on of some old family beef
the Greyjoy rebellion about ten years
ago Balin rebelled against the crown so
the rest of Westeros got together and
put him down which was pretty sweet a
young Robert and Ned and Stannis and
Tywin and Barry and Thoris and Gregor
and Jorah and Jamie all fought together
against the Greyjoy's the Greyjoy is
lost of course but what is dead can
never die and now Euron's back offering
his hand both hands to Cersei in
marriage she says no but he says he'll
return with a gift so what's he planning
so she did just mention how much he
hates Tyrion and Tyrion has been offered
as a gift to a queen before so maybe
Iran has eyes on the dwarf in old town
at the Citadel Sam's weighing brains and
stacking scrolls and scooping soup than
scrubbing poop Game of Thrones Hogwarts
is not as fun as he thought it would be
he came here to learn secrets that would
help in the fight against the walkers
but no one here seems to believe that
they even exist archmaester Eber assures
him that every other time someone
thought the world would end it didn't
but Sam has seen that the threat is real
so he breaks into the restricted section
of the library just like in Harry Potter
to find something to help against the
walkers this might relate to something
that's happening in the books when Jack
and had da breaks into the Citadel go
watch that video but in the show Sam
gets a book about dragonglass the stuff
that kills white walkers and he learns
of huge caves beneath dragon stone that
a full of dragonglass
which will be SuperDuper useful against
the walkers for the record Stannis
already told Sam
about that dragonglass but who listens
to Stannis right later we find Jorah is
at the Citadel suffering from greyscale
Dany ordered him to find a cure remember
and it might just be that the book Sam
found could hold the answer the page
mentions dragonglass as a cure for
illnesses and disease it mentions
ingestion so maybe eating dragon glass
can cure greyscale it would be quite
weird if the same stuff that created
White Walkers who can make ice zombies
can save people from greyscale which
makes stone zombies there are lots of
different types of zombies in Thrones
maybe they're all somehow connected one
other thing this knife on this page
about Valyrian weapons looks just like
the cat's-paws blade that Littlefinger
used to frame Tyrion the same knife that
Isle wears on a magazine cover it's not
clear what the point of all this will be
but it sure looks like this particular
dagger is important it's only episode 1
and Sam is already making discoveries
back at Winterfell for a moment pod gets
his ass beat by Brienne and tormund
wishes it was him Peter craves on Sansa
but she swiftly shuts him down
Littlefinger used to be an amazing
scheme with a complex plot in the early
story but now he mostly hangs around and
says snide [ __ ]
he's going to have to do something if
he's to survive this season we then get
a scene with the coolest new squad in
the story Storace barrack and the Hound
Sandor Clegane they stay at a farmhouse
and Sandor has been here before in
season 4 the Hound and i--i stayed with
a farmer and his daughter here Sandor
mugged the farmer and said they'd die by
winter but now when he finds them dead
he shows regret and pays his respects by
burying them the act of grave digging
refers to a bit in the books where after
his apparent death The Hound becomes a
monk and digs graves as penance for his
sins
a peaceful land for the character in the
books in the show the hounds wars are
not over but the point of his grave
digging seems the same Sandor used to be
a remorseless killer remember when he
killed that kid Micah in season 1 but
now he has some humanity and respect for
life
back when sandal hung out with aya he
was always the brutal one while she
wanted mercy now it's the other way
around
aya remorselessly slaughters while the
hound mourns the dead how will these
guys get along if they ever meet again
sand or barrack and sores talk about
destiny and God the hound overcomes his
fear of fire and looks into a flame
seeing a vision of the marching dead by
a castle where the wall needs to see so
that's east watch where John sent the
wildlings and in the books Melisandre
does predict that the Dead will attack
their butts and all also sees a mountain
that looks like an arrowhead it's not
clear what that means the mountain could
mean a place like the fist of the first
men
or maybe the Obsidian a dragon stone or
a symbolic mountain like the hounds
brother Gregor
or a zombie giant maybe and that
Arrowhead bid could mean dragonglass
arrowheads
maybe it's hard to say but one thing is
clear that the dead are marching on east
watch the final thing is something that
readers have waited for for decades
20 years ago the first book came out and
ever since fans have hoped to see
Daenerys arrive at Dragonstone her home
where she was born where her ancestors
the Dragonlords lived for centuries and
a starting point for Danny's campaign to
take the throne there is a sweet Satan
Stannis its banner and sand is rough and
coarse and it kind of makes no sense
that this castle is abandoned but the
significance of this scene is as the
beginning of the end the start of the
final act in the story of Game of
Thrones
thanks for watching subscribe for a new
video for each episode every week you
can also support this channel on patreon
we're holding live streams after each
episode answering questions and talking
Thrones if you want to join in become a
patron at the link below thanks to
patrons Lois Hennessey Jesse Seville
Bill Miller Randy wertham and Verna key
Francoise Bernard 7e Amy McDermott and
duck Cheers
you